what are you watching because i have
started watching stuff
i never would have watched otherwise i'm
watching this show
that people tell me it's been on forever
that's called
selling sunset it's like a uh
and everyone watching is like conan
where have you been
but it's a reality tv show where they
just sell
uh upscale real estate in west hollywood
i started watching that uh and
i don't like real estate agents i don't
want to spend time with them
in my free time i know i don't either
i'm not even saying i'm enjoying it
i'm just taking advantage of us
it's a sign of the times that i'm
watching a show and my assistant told me
oh it doesn't really get good till
season three yes this is what i would
say
and i'm watching and that's what people
say and i'm watching it
i'm watching this show and i'm going
like yeah it's still not really
nothing's happening
but i guess i have to watch two full
seasons till something picks up
i never had that kind of patience for a
show before you used to hear that about
the wire
yeah you gotta get to the seasons of the
idris elba it's like i think that's
season three or four
like okay so i need to get 30 in
whoever by the way season one of the
wire is great so it was a lie
whoever whoever said that about any i
mean but
are you doing that now or you because
people have that's a common thing i keep
hearing is
just get through five seasons and then
it really picks up
but you've gotta watch the first five
you gotta get halfway through season
four game of thrones then it really
kicks in
[Laughter]
my wife and i we have so many uh you
know uh binging fights
we're always fighting about that because
uh she does not follow any
binge rule uh like i will go
uh somewhere uh you know like say we get
like a little tiff
you know get a little tiff and we're
watching uh like we were watching prime
suspect starring helen mirren which is
on hulu great
english show classic old show i like how
you said helen mirren helen
mirren like what are you going to do
about it it's not a bar
fight alan mirren helen neary
what are you going to do about it you
want to take me on now
is it good so yes so it stars um
helen mirren and uh now it's woody allen
it's helen niren and
and so we get into like a little a
little tip about something
and then you know uh next time i turn it
on she's
three seasons forward she's left
three seasons and also doesn't care
like i'll go well what's going on she's
like google it
google it go read a summary of previous
seasons
see to me that's a contract if i'm
watching something with my wife
and we there's an implicit implied
contract that this is a show we watch
together
then later on i find out that she's gone
a whole season ahead of me
yeah that's like waking up in the
wilderness and your partner
left early in the morning and took the
thermos and the food
you know what i mean and you and they're
just gone
they went up the trail without you
that's a betrayal yeah my
my uh my wife watched uh the last season
of the crown without me
and then you're in a situation where
you're like well when am i gonna get to
watch it alone
i don't have this kind of time i only
got eight hours
where you're gonna let me hang out alone
to catch up on the crown
we have to be in sync as a couple this
is very important
uh we watch a lot of dateline i find
that you know for some reason that's our
comfort
show yeah dateline because it's very
it's you know it's a
about murder generally but for some
reason the way they edit it
they cut away before anyone has feelings
you know they just briskly move through
the murder you know you'll see a
documentary and something there's a
murder and people cry and they feel and
you're devastated but
dateline it's it's kind of bouncy and
and lights
through murder i think it's strange too
because i agree with you i love
uh dateline and i find it strange
that murder has become our comfort food
do you know what i mean yes it's just
this is where the body was found the
head's missing but we found one of the
feet
and you're watching it like this is
this is chicken soup for the soul you
know i'm not sure why that is
i i don't know if it's like at least i
haven't been murdered
or life is better than this
but also i do feel like i'm i'm
experiencing it with
them but also i enjoy the hosts because
they're just so strange and they ask
like weird
questions ever since bill hader did
impressions of every
host i only think of bill while i watch
the show because they're always just
going like
well that must have felt good and and i
just think of bill like it's like his
head is um
yeah he ruined it for everybody bill
hater ruined it for everybody